Attention, pas d'insulte
gratuite chez moi.
Quand je parle
de phrases de connards,
je parle de phrases qui trahissent
de la prétention ou de l'égoïsme.
Voilà une phrase de connards que certains mecs
aiment bien dire quand ils viennent de se réveiller.
Ah, désolé, moi, tant que j'ai pas eu
mon café, je peux rien faire !
Heu... Heureusement que les mecs qui disent ça,
se retrouvent pas dans une situation d'urgence.
À l'aide ! À l'aide !
Je me suis fait écraser !
Emmenez-moi à l'hôpital !
Ah, désolé, moi, tant que j'ai pas eu
mon café, je peux rien faire !
Ah ben ça tombe bien.
Tenez ! Un expresso noir sans sucre.
Merci ! Bonne journée !
Il y a une bonne phrase
de connards aussi, c'est celle-ci :
Ouais, je te parle mal ! Mais ça va, c'est bon !
Je suis pas du matin !
Comme si cette phrase suffisait à excuser
des paroles ou des actes hyper agressifs !
Vous êtes responsable de l'un des plus
gros génocides de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Vous avez quoi à dire
pour votre défense ?
Disons que moi,
je suis pas du matin.
Donc, très vite on fait
des conneries, quoi !
Bon bah, ça va, alors !
Dans le même genre, pour se justifier d'avoir
mal parlé à quelqu'un, certains mecs disent :
Bah ouais !
Désolé si j'ai fait un scandale à table,
si ta mère a chialé,
si le pacemaker de ton oncle a lâché,
mais c'est comme ça,
je suis un mec entier !
Ouais ! T'es un connard entier, quoi !
Une bonne phrase de connards égoïstes,
qu'on entend malheureusement trop souvent :
Bah, toute façon, moi,
je donne par d'argent aux SDF,
parce que si je leur donne de l'argent, avec,
ils vont acheter de l'alcool !
Donc...
En plus, cette phrase est débile !
Le pauvre SDF qui vit dehors
à moins dix degrés en hiver,
bah il achète
ce qu'il peut pour tenir.
Les mecs qui sortent cette phrase,
ils espèrent quoi ?
Que le SDF, il va arriver au supermarché
et qu'avec leur argent, il va acheter ça ?
Alors, je vais vous prendre
un petit sirop de papaye bio sans gluten,
une clé USB 32Go, si possible
compatible avec mon MacBook Pro.
Thanks !
Une phrase de connard, qui veut bien
montrer qu'il a du caractère :
Moi je m'énerve pas souvent, mais je peux te dire,
quand on me cherche, on me trouve !
C'est une évidence !
Tout le monde, quand on le cherche,
s'énerve au bout d'un moment.
Ça peut jamais être l'inverse !
Moi, je suis un gros vénère !
Un mec vénère de ouf,
tout le temps !
Mais quand on me cherche, là
je peux te dire, là je deviens cool !
Là, je peux t'inviter
à faire un mini-golf.
Moi, je suis un cas un peu spécial,
parce que j'ai un visage de mec gentil.
C'est-à-dire que moi, quand je m'énerve,
les gens n'ont pas peur.
Chloé, c'est abusé !
T'as même pas rangé ta chambre !
Ouin !
La phrase de connard
la plus universelle, c'est celle-là :
Je suis pas raciste, mais...
Une phrase qui commence par
"Je suis pas raciste, mais..."
ne pourra jamais bien se finir.
Elle ne pourra jamais se finir
par un truc intelligent.
C'est sûr !
Je suis pas raciste,
mais je pense
que tous les hommes naissent
libres et égaux en droit.
Impossible !
Voilà !
Voilà la phrase de connard d'un hipster
qui veut faire son malin en parlant de cinéma :
Django, ouais, bon, c'est un peu
Quentin qui fait du Tarantino, quoi !
Cette phrase n'existe
que pour se la péter,
c'est sûr, que pour montrer
qu'on a un avis un peu différent des autres,
en parlant d'un génie connu
que tout le monde aime bien.
Ça marche pas avec un mec
que les gens aiment pas,
du genre un méchant
ou un pédophile.
Bon, c'est un peu Marc
qui fait du Dutroux, quoi !
Parmi les phrases de connards,
il y a les mecs qui se décrivent en mots-clés.
Bah, toute façon, moi,
je suis très grands vins,
je suis très
brunchs entre amis,
bon, je suis très
France Inter,
je suis très
David Lynch,
je suis très...
T'es très chiant aussi !
Mouais, je suis
très chiant aussi.
Bon, je suis très
vinyles de jazz,
je suis très double péné, ouais,
ça, c'est un truc que j'aime,
je suis très ...
Si t'as apprécié ma vidéo, tu peux la partager
ou t'abonner à ma chaîne YouTube.
Attends, je peux pas m'abonner,
tant que j'ai pas eu mon café.
En plus, moi,
je suis pas du matin !
Ben tiens, ton café !
Tu peux t'abonner maintenant ?
D'accord. Je m'abonne, mais c'est vraiment
Norman qui fait du "Norman fait des vidéos", quoi !
J'en profite pour vous dire
un très, très gros merci,
parce que mon spectacle "Norman sur scène"
est plein à craquer à Paris.
Ça y est, La Cigale, 20 dates complètes,
merci beaucoup !
J'ai donc ouvert
deux mois supplémentaires
au Théâtre de Bobino à Paris.
J'ai hâte de vous y voir ! Love !
J'adore le concept !
Ma nouvelle caisse...
Le Kinder Surprise
de mes rêves...
Mmh ! Ouais !
Oh putain !